doesn't even miss a beat Sega Genesis play
almost what a move I don't believe what I
just saw Cloud will turn and fire it down the
middle and that could have been a breakaways
but David knocked it down and he's working
over from Jam spins Waits still waiting get
whater goore what an unbelievable feed from
MCD and M Cloud the Finish spectacular but
when he wants a puck back he's one of
the best in the league and taking it
off of an opponent eyes the back of his
head on a beautiful little spin backand
path and his son here Matias oh what a
what a beautiful backand by marenko not
only is it a back I think it's a forehead
Jeff pulls it between the legs and roofi
it's between two sets of legs actually and it
ends up going right there past Levi top shelf
Anderson on the puck waits to stay outside plays
it for cofio if he moov Anderson does a nice job
of cutting across the Blue Line holding on to it
till Coffield can get into place slides it over
to him what a nice move on the rookie kinsky
although he doesn't get in across he gets to
the inside of his backand gets it upstairs
and it finds its way down the back of moric
and into the net one nothing monreal po free
by Kane and now oh McDavid what a spin the
recovery the shot score he goes down spinorama
pops back up and somehow that puck was loose I
mean that is absolute nightmare for that puck to
be ahead of him when he gets up but he attacks
with so much speed doesn't even miss a beat
and then buries it on the Breakaway wow it's
like a wacka you thought he was gone and you
just popped right back up me come on it's just
unfair great it's one timer over the head
of lukin put in and gny Maran with some
absolute sorcery from the corner when
you least expect it a bank in from the
bad angle off the helmet on a one-time on the
backand Sega Genesis play almost just held down
the shoot button and released a backhand
one timer off the end boards off lucan's
mind Nan Hopkins speaking about my pass McDavid
Cuts in wait Waits TS it home Conor McDavid a
virtuoso game time goal the watch this paent
stick handle stick handle get flurry to bite
you know Mark Andre flurry's an aggressive Bender
wants to come out and challenge that's exactly
what he does but the patience the skill of Conor
McDavid to walk this around tuck it home on the
backhand side absolutely ridiculous [Music]
goal he takes a turn without TJ Ro alongside
solid Mar front go more Mitch Mar magic yeah
what a set of hands here by Marner and just
ice cold in his veins on the turn around Marner
takes him one way knocks it the quick little spin
around Skinner goes out for the Poke check
and then off the post off the other and back
in glass weaves it down low Marette for
the leg score yes sir a spectacular goal
you so personated did you see that through the
legs behind the foot and up in the top Corner
look at this right under the bar and beats
Guston clean what a move by [Music] Parson
rope hits henan has a lot of room sends it down
low hoping for a tip Robertson batted it in out
of midair Jason Robertson he takes the tip
and double tips it into the air to himself
good save here by Hill and Robertson bunts
it once butts it twice that's exceptional
concentration and focus to be able to take
the puck in the air twice and SWAT it into
the net really unhappy extra attacker on Yamamoto
giving way McDavid Drive CLE shoots and scores
finding a sliver of daylight underneath the bar
unbelievable Marksmanship but in the process he
puts the net back he has the wherewith all
to say hey we've got possession here we're
going to move it around and look at this not a
whole lot of room but he recognizes that David
rck is down he goes head hunting put it right
for the head nothing you can do on that shot
sers drops it back in comes a pass the he BS
it in foot an incredible hand play ver oh what
a goal he's got a wait for it to drop and he does
ways TI chokes down on the blade more control and
bats it past a sprawling Jame rmer home run swing
walkoff is what it is with 10 first CL oh that's
brilliant brilliant stuff seconds left in overtime
pulled off the puck by Yamamoto now McDavid Breaks
Loose little spin move on his back hand scores
Sensational goal for the captain Conor McDavid
McDavid picks it up little spin move and he just
leav Zer in the dust there he can stop so quickly
watch the Slams on the brakes watch him fly
right by in a beautiful backand finish for Conor
mcdavis I think he was a little unsure of what was
around it now her with the pass between the legs
and then barov scores what a move it looks like
barkov's going to go between the legs here Kenny
but he I don't think he ever does oh and he brings
it back so he made it looked like he was going to
go and make that move between the legs and then
the patience here Jones need to wait wait wait
and then have the angle to beat R yeah what a of
hands right look at that they've been battling
they battle back in the game they're battling for
these loose Parts jari he's going for the empty
net bouncing towards the goal he scor you have
witnessed history Tristan jari becomes the first
goenda goal wow was that with some authority too
Tristan jari had himself a whale of a
game and oh yeah he just scored a goal
wow Carin off besser stick omark is going to
try it and he scores latest Omar the odds on V
Trophy winner scores an empty net goal to seal
this win you're seeing [Applause] history the
S [Applause] line they are set up Maran turn side
of the net between the legs and they score filthy
David poock the power play Go the creativity the
speed and how he makes this So Graceful bar Shan
goes down quickly and how that play by poo he's
in Reverse as he picks it up he does not stop
that motion at all he just Glides it through
the legs and pop SH now the Ducks will break
out Harrington stro sauces the ZR between the
legs oh my goodness he's done it again through
his legs top shelf and it's two to one he likes
to show off for John bagr I'm telling you the
games that you do he comes up with something like
this not just that then go up and over the blocker
side for the finish what a goal sealer a shot
block gets it back sealer moves inside outside
inside of the scores Nick sealer how do you do a
thing of beauty what did we just see Nick sealer
scor SC the goal of the year for the Flyers
moments ago Jay Theodore Bray McNab Jonathan
quck as Michael took that pass away Savers get
it back again here's Benson in front what a
move scores Zack bson with his first NHL goal
and that is a beauty to remember for all time
this is total confidence going to the front of
the net and he pulls his back between his legs
he's going to put it right up top underneath
the bar No Way Camper expecting this and look
at how easy it was just simple effective and
clean you said yeah that is a beauty and look
at the young man's smiling right there Bard
shoots wide to the stick side of Bennington
Kev plays the rebound for Bard down low Bard the
cross style scores what a play I don't believe
what I just saw otherworldly skill here as he
just softly picks that up on his St goes up
over the shoulder he knew exactly what he was
going to do take it off the board protects it
and reversed it in as a right hand shot and
tucked it by the glove we have not seen him
do that in a game situation just yet but the
kids got some marvelous hands dude that was
insane mikov brings it back in drops it off to
zis Trevor takes it in behind the that he scores
on the cross goal the thing about zis when he
does this and executes it is he's moving I've
seen a lot of guys try it but not while they're
skating at almost full speed what a beautiful play
by TR eers I think most of the crowd is just
now realizing what he did cuz they showed the
replay a couple of times on the big board above
center right and the reaction got a great deal
louder current coyote 3 to one Coyote's
dancing coie scores what a goal by the
youngster look at this I mentioned earlier
that he's a dancer watch the dance move
right there and then gets himself s in
a position when he spins the second time
he's in a perfect shooting position and he
uses everything to hoist that puck quickly
to the top of the net that is something
you cannot teach that is pure skill big
smile jackets get it back head Johnson
Lee unable to get a stick on it look
at that it is the Michigan Kent Johnson
circles the and then sends it home it's
3o Columbus unbelievable and he doesn't do
the wrap around he goes for the Michigan
something this kid does all the time in
practice and that's his first Michigan
in the National Hockey League stuffit
top show highlight real goal [Music]
[Music] here [Music]
a